the temperature is so cold exposed human
skin freezes solid in less than an hour
the air is so thin
the average unadjusted person would die
within minutes a man named norm is
huddled with his best friend Chris on
the face of the southeast Ridge towards
the summit of Mount Everest after an
unexpected storm they have been
separated from the rest of the group of
tourists climbers because of the
conditions Chris's body has begun
shutting down and is incapable of
holding balance forcing him to stop in
one of the most dangerous sections of
the mountain norm Chris and norms wife
Jill I had decided a little over a year
ago that they were going to climb Mount
Everest together for norms 39th birthday
the idea for the trip sprang up during a
moderately drunk conversation about life
and getting old in a bar they talked
about how it felt like their life was
slipping away from them how they were
wasting their remaining prime adult
years and monotonous routines with
little to no excitement anymore then
they reminisced about pastimes and trips
filled with hiking and climbing
adventures they lamented over how long
it had been they recalled memories of
their 20s and early 30s hiking some of
the greatest trails and climbing some of
the greatest mountains in the world by
the end of the conversation they
promised each other that by this time
next year they would climb Mount Everest
together and feel that sense of wonder
and excitement again now one year later
norm and Chris are sitting at the
highest point of Earth's crust at their
lowest points ever imaginable its norms
39th birthday today
Jill is waiting safely back at base camp
after experiencing challenges with the
ascent and was guided back down by a
Sherpa before the storm norm is better
off than Chris but not by much and won't
be for long inside norms gloves
frostbite is moving from his fingertips
down his hands both him and Chris are
running dangerously low on oxygen and
their oxygen tanks have almost
completely run out with only traces of
additional breaths left to be split
between them norm can go back down
himself but fears that if he leaves
Chris will die with certainty he hopes
that both their body heat and supplies
can hold them over until the storm
passes and they can get more oxygen sent
up to re-stabilize Chris and bring him
down
gnorm is not in the most rational state
of mind as more time passes
Chris's speech wanes as his
consciousness begins to freeze inside
his head
realizing what is happening norm gets
the base camp to radio and Chris's wife
for him Chris struggles to get words out
as his wife cries amidst the static on
the other line they say they love each
other they talk about what they're going
to do when Chris gets home and then
Chris tells her to tell his only son his
parents and brother that he loves them
and he sorry not long after the call
Chris goes to sleep for the last time
by this point norm is holding on by a
thread he leaves Chris now that he is
sure there is no hope left norm
traverses back down the face of the
mountain struggling through the storm
using every neuron in his brain to move
his legs one step at a time by
unbelievable odds he makes it close
enough to Basecamp to be intercepted and
taken the rest of the way on a stretcher
just before passing out of lethal levels
of oxygen deficiency it's two weeks
later norm is safe at home his left hand
and left foot have been amputated far
scarier he has been in an unresponsive
catatonic state ever since returning
home doctors weren't able to find any
physical tangible abnormalities in his
brain but suspected the oxygen
deficiency subsequent seizures and
psychological damage from the trauma of
the experience all combined to cause
norms strange state norms capable of
moving and talking but doesn't do much
of either it's as if all of his interest
and motivation is gone and asking him to
say or do anything is like asking
someone to learn how to throw a baseball
80 miles per hour
who doesn't like baseball two months go
by norm has been going four times a week
to a psychiatrist specializing in trauma
psychotherapy slowly norm has begun to
come out of his withdrawn silent state
but something remains very strange after
struggling to pin down exactly what is
wrong
the psychiatrist finally diagnoses norm
with a rare extreme form of a mental
condition
as anhedonia norm his parents and Jill
sit in a psychiatrist's office while the
psychiatrist explains the diagnosis it's
hard to understand I'm sure but
essentially norm has lost the ability to
attribute any significance to sensations
and emotions
he's just experiencing things as things
what do you mean things as things things
are just things norms father confusingly
interrupts yes but I mean he isn't
distinguishing the different qualities
of things like he's not processing the
difference between pleasure or pain
beauty or ugliness blue or red exciting
or dull etc everything is sort of just a
different image of the same thing the
psychiatrist explains how is that even
possible
Norma's mother emotionally emits
something like this is pretty rare so
it's hard to know exactly what is
happening but cases of anhedonia and
other mental disorders like it are
typically triggered from PTSD or major
depression or both this case is
especially strange and extreme but
between the lack of oxygen the seizures
and a psychological trauma it
unfortunately kind of adds up the
psychiatrist replies is it permanent or
Jill speaks up for the first time but
with the uncertainty comes the
possibility that it gets better if it's
purely psychological then I think it's
possible that he makes a recovery and
comes out of it I've certainly seen
stranger things happen the psychiatrist
says to try to offer some comfort norms
mother begins to cry norm sits a
pathetically unconcerned by the news the
psychiatrist goes on and says I think
there are a lot of things that can be
done to help the situation and put a
little more force on norms brain I'm
going to suggest that norm comes in six
days a week so I can begin them on a
more intensive talk therapy process
there are also several other medications
and combinations and medications we can
try it's likely going to be a long road
but it's not hopeless over a year goes
by norms condition has not improved much
the anti depression medications don't
seem to help a lot and the talk therapy
has only helped norm function better
with his condition
than fix it at its core Norma's also
tried electroconvulsive therapy which
uses electrical currents to stimulate
the brain which also didn't have any
significant success since that day on
the mountain norm has not felt anything
good or bad colours look different but
don't feel different what used to be his
favorite meal tastes the same as what
used to be his least favorite his wife
doesn't look better or worse than any
other woman a cloudy day feels the same
as a sunny day even as memories have no
associated feelings or qualities to them
they're like looking at photos from
somebody else's past everything is the
same so nothing really is at all Jill
and norms family and friends have become
increasingly scared and desperate the
strain on the family and norm and Jill's
relationship is beginning to boil over
it's like living and interacting with
the shell of a person fully intact with
nothing inside or like a robot but one
with a face that reminds you in every
moment that it should be a person Jill
still sees the person she fell in love
with in his eyes though and too many
other people surprised she continues to
stay with norm refusing to give up on
him another year and a half goes by
seemingly out of nowhere the FDA
approves a brand new depression
medication that is the first
functionally different depression
medication in decades the medication is
derived from the drug known as ketamine
which had previously been used to induce
and sustain surgical anesthesia as well
as used illegally to experience
recreational hallucinogenic highs after
Yale University's research labs found
ketamine to be highly successful in
improving treatment resistant depression
disorders it is federally approved in
certain forms and released into the
market the medication essentially makes
the brain malleable enough to be shaped
and reshaped by affecting
neurotransmitters and allowing the brain
to form new neural connections norm
psychiatrist prescribes it in order to
facilitate the effectiveness of the
medication though it is essential that
norm also works through a variety of
complementary cycle therapeutic
practices as part of this norm
psychiatrist tells Jill and the rest of
norms family that they should spend some
time each day describing things to norm
little details of things and little
nuances of emotions how food tastes how
colors make them feel what things are
appealing to look at what hurts in what
feels good what's boring and what
everything in his daily life in the
following months Jill does this every
day with norm at first she struggles to
communicate sensations and experiences
with words especially as norms questions
become more and more complicated and
specific but she gets better and better
she finds herself noticing the tiniest
hidden details in each moment of each
thing the different sounding homes in
the backgrounds of each location the
different smells in each pocket of air
the way different rays of Sun feel on
her skin the way our tongue seems to
vibrate differently with each different
type of food the way the textures of
different materials make her feel how
different layers of all the sounds odors
taste colors Lighting's objects and
feelings all work together to create a
different scene of the world in each
moment like watching the same movie over
and over again but noticing something
completely different each time norm uses
every neuron in his brain to try to feel
what Jill feels it's the hardest thing
he's ever done trying to feel and
imagine each thing she describes it's
like climbing the mountain all over
again after more than a year of effort
goes by the treatment is successful
Norma's slowly begun to feel again it's
a miracle to his friends and family like
he's been born again and given a second
chance they're overwhelmed with bliss
and relief for the first time in years
norm can feel what they feel in these
moments of happiness and appreciation as
part of his continuous recovery process
he picks at least one thing each day to
describe in detail an object a color a
taste and odor a feeling and whatever
else Jill continues to do this with norm
even though she doesn't have to anymore
today norm and Jill are lying together
on the ground in their living room
they're on their sides as they look at
feel and describe their living room
carpet they talk about how soft and
comfortable it is how it's like a patch
of indoor grass for humans without all
the dirt and bugs they laugh at this
they talk about the details on each
little fiber and how each little fiber
builds into the whole carpet making the
room cozy and beautiful
in this particular moment norm and Jill
feel a sense of happiness and wonder
[Music]
you